[Music]
the first question I got about my book
when it came out in February as I was
going around the country talking about
it was does your book explain Donald
Trump so I had to come up with some sort
of answer that dressed that that issue
and the answer that I have is yes the
story of Donald Trump is the story of
the Billboard Hot 100
so the Billboard Hot 100 invented the
1950s is the official register of
popularity in music and for a long time
it was essentially fake it was fake news
they could they didn't have live records
of what albums what vinyl was selling
week by week so instead what they did is
they surveyed the DJ's and the record
store owners and both parties would lie
the DJ's would lie because they were
being paid by these studios and the
labels and the record store owners would
lie because they had scarcity and once
you've sold say all of your Bruce
Springsteen and you have a lot of ac/dc
then it doesn't make any sense to tell a
billboard that Bruce Springsteen is
selling you need to sell more ac/dc Stan
you tell them that that album is now
number one in the charts so the buy so
the the charts were biased toward the
tastes of the white men at the labels
and torture and then in 1991 all of that
changed billboard introduced new
technology to measure a point of sales
data of records and to measure radio
play and immediately taste the music
changed overnight a hip hop and country
overlooked by white guys in the coast
soared up the charts and the churn of
the Billboard Hot 100 slowed down
dramatically such that I think that 20
songs that have been on the Billboard
Hot 100 for the longest period of time
have all come out in the last 25 years
so essentially you could say that taste
and music went from being dictated top
down to being generated bottom up the
exact same thing is happening in
politics for a long time there was this
theory of politics called the party
decides and this said that the way that
we choose presidential candidates or
presidential nominees with the parties
is not that the public dictates who will
be the party nominees but rather that
elites at the party level decide and
they distribute their messages through
scarce media channels like television
and radio and the
public eats it up not altogether unlike
the way that the studios are sorry the
labels could dictate music popularity
and then radio listeners would just eat
it up and like those songs because of
familiarity but what happened with
Donald Trump and Jeb Bush the
establishment candidate that all of the
party people like did terribly and
Donald Trump who had basically no elite
party support did terrifically within
the Republican Party and so I guess I
think within the party structure you
could also say that tastes which used to
be dictated top-down are now being
dictated bottom-up and we are I think we
are seeing a groundswell of the bottom
across the entertainment a political
landscape that because of the
distribution of media channels it is too
difficult now for any gatekeeper to
control the flow of information from a
group of elite people to the masses
instead everybody has a bullhorn
everybody can be a broadcaster and as a
result what you have instead is chaos
and so I think that that is one of the
more important phenomena that we're
seeing is this revolution of bottom-up
that is powered by a technological
revolution in distribution
[Music]